yo blue light cab podcast uh
very special episode three of these guys
in the same place doing an interview you
guys ever done an interview all together
no
generation now man cannon dj drama the
homie lake
uh appreciate you guys for pulling up
man well i pulled up on y'all actually
so appreciate you
yeah listen man like i'm here i've been
obviously wanting to talk to john for a
long time
um but i think it's so dope to have all
three you guys here
i heard that uh this is the first time
you've been in the studio for a long
time since march
damn she feels very special yeah
damn special mm-hmm that's it and
i had to i had to come out for kev i
appreciate that man
um i would get ghosts most of the time
so i got so much [ __ ] i want to like
dive in
with you guys on because i know you've
been a lot of people don't know
like you're kind of the man behind the
scenes that people probably know the
least so kind of
break down who you are what you do damn
you want me
they know these guys these guys are you
know yeah no they do what they do
i mean and i like it that way um
i don't even know how to describe it man
i feel like i'm just like the third
piece of the puzzle you know it kind of
makes the uh
makes the the wheels turn behind the
scenes you know
um uh we'd like to describe it as like
uh canon's the music drums the face and
i'm the business so we'll just put it
that way
so you handle the business to an extent
don't be modest dogging some of your
history
break down a little bit just run a nice
little quick rundown uh
started off managing people uh used to
work with freeway they
worked with the the state property guys
for a minute worked with bobby valentino
worked with dram work with mace actually
that's what i started with oh you
started with mace
what year uh this is the welcome back
era
okay okay so that's the first person was
that the opportunity wait welcome so
that was was that the album where he had
the the brewer's hat on the cover that
is the hat where the
brewers had covered yeah um
so you know been around uh been working
with these guys ever since we actually
all went to school together where they
went to clark i went to morehouse which
is like right next right
right yeah so and if you've ever been to
a nightclub that dj drama's dj'd at
he's there yeah at all passing out shots
to str strange women nonetheless um
blunt in his hand with a blunt in his
hand for sure no i mean
you guys have obviously you know done
something special with generation now i
feel like um
you know dram like you being who you are
and being a dj and and
like successfully and we're not just
talking about successfully doing the
label [ __ ]
like we're talking about like uzi's one
of the biggest
[ __ ] artists of the last decade jack
harlow's superstar right now
so like not only are you like doing your
thing because it you know with your
connections you could do your thing with
whoever
is on your roster but to like really
really
um be like a prominent
source of new talent in the music
industry um
it's just impressive man like you guys
have built something really special
no i appreciate that um it's very
rewarding like
you know like just to think about
my career and the successes i've had as
a dj and
you know we've had as a um coming up as
the affiliates and
and you know putting things together and
projects and and doing it and just
really elevating and
you know and in some senses it feels
like reinvention
you know and just even somebody brought
it up today like you know like
or i put a tweet up that i just found on
on twitter and this guy said um he said
um dj drama really went from ti
to gz to uzi to jack harlow that's crazy
you know and i was like you know it was
it was that was like the highest praise
for me how i felt
you know i mean [ __ ] dude i tweeted uh
earlier or later last year
you're the greatest of all time yeah i i
appreciate that i forgot about that you
did that was a that was an interesting
combo yeah i was watching that um
that versus and i was like yo like
drama's got his hands all over this
entire like
like atlanta is arguably the most
important city
in like it's new york obviously for sure
but atlanta like
atlanta is where everything is the
culture starts here
and everyone else follows atlanta and
it's been like that for
15 years i'd say even maybe 20 20 maybe
20. right i feel like
atlanta's had the most dominant run in
hip-hop over
and like i just don't feel like anyone
has ever had more
moments and influence and just um have
been a part of more history than you
good looking
and by the way amazing dj as well i
appreciate that yeah
um we try to cover all all grounds all
capacity and
you know it's just like it really is
because you know
a lot of [ __ ] like i've been doing it
for so long and
you know just the just to i
i and we try not to get comfortable on
what we've accomplished already
and then you know just like being able
to
navigate and you know being a dj it's
like
because we we play music and we've been
able to navigate through
hip hop through a lot of times it's like
you know that keeps me
on a cusp and keeps me like really
addicted to new [ __ ] like at all times
you know i'm saying so
um so yeah i mean it's my my my dj hat
has
has been very helpful in you know the
career as an executive and
you know finding and you know helping
new talent and you know
turning into what we did and of course
you know slew of hit records
in your own right you know for sure um i
don't know and then you guys
um i'm curious too because i was when i
was just talking with seti hendrix and
what i appreciate about
generation now is you guys truly like
every artist really is getting it out
the mud like it's not like
there's not a [ __ ] magic switch to
hit like people really think jack
harlow's a new artist
but if you've been tapped in like he's
been doing his thing with y'all for like
three years
and you know and the same thing with
seti like
i think that like the work is what kind
of you know
i feel like you guys are very conscious
of the work
like and making sure like hey look it's
not as much because you
you guys could probably sign whoever you
know what i'm saying
but you guys definitely take the long
way like someone like jack harlow
who this it's not like he had a buzzing
single
and you guys grabbed them up right and
then just you know
threw some gasoline on the fire you guys
built the [ __ ] fire
from the from the jump um so talk about
that like just
your guys is like talent process like
what is it you got to see an
artist to want to bring them over to
generation now and the same thing can be
said about uzi too by the way what do
you see an artist
conviction uh inspired artist a lot of
artists come to you they're not inspired
you know what i mean they just
don't have a vision uh they just wanna
rap
and i you know i personally just you
know me and john working so long we've
known it you know see we've known when
we seen people with conviction
the people that used to be at you know
532 glen iris was like
his house that was the hub for all this
you know mm-hmm
how was that that's where gangster girls
were and we still just watched so many
people like we watched david banner come
in the white van and be like yo i'm not
leaving until i get against the girls
you know paul wall came down here and we
used to do houston
latex new york parties and he's like
rapping you know what i'm saying
certain people you just the eyes just
tell it all for them you know
and i think that's what happened a lot
of artists like jack came in that was
the eyes you know
even seti like a lot of the artists you
just know
you know it's that feeling like oh they
gonna do whatever it takes
to get there you know what i mean yeah i
think there's they all have that in
common like that's one thing i could say
about their instinct
definitely the three of them you know
and when it comes to
generational only but when i think about
uzi jack and seti like
their passion and their like i'm
i'm gonna get there like all three of
them have
have that instinctively and like to a
thousandth degree
yeah i i saw something on twitter it's
like it you can't
want it more than your management or
your label once
then you're wasting everyone's time and
i feel like a lot of artists like you'll
meet
that are fire and you know
[ __ ] just doesn't work out and it's and
it's really like they're
lacking in that they're doing music
because they can not because they like
they want to you know
absolutely absolutely um take me back to
oh seven man because listen i gotta
drama i gotta thank you and and and you
can
because um i made so much money selling
gangster grill mix teams from the time i
was 16
that's why the name mr thanksgiving came
from because i used to go
on all the message boards download all
the tapes
go on mixunit.com steal the artwork fire
i had the [ __ ] printer at the crib
friend go to the office max get the
jewel cases that's a good old day how
much how much you think you made
dude every weekend i was at least i mean
i was like 17
yeah i got the swap meet i had my little
space at the saw i mean i was probably
making like a rack a weekend so that's
great
it's five bucks a tape or five for
twenty yeah it was it was drama it was
you and the southern smoke [ __ ]
just that [ __ ] shot the small small yep
june the radio of course as well
but yeah it you know the mixtape era was
so
special and it was like it was just
there was just something about it that
that i don't know if we'll ever get back
um but you know you obviously
you're the biggest mixtape bj of all
time but when you got arrested i
remember buying the um
i bought a free drama shirt off of uh
get out of here off a mixed unit
first time i ever met you i was wearing
it actually in phoenix so when we met
wasn't it like right after the it was
the same it was 07 right
i met you when i was like a scrub in
phoenix yeah i was i was working at a
radio so maybe it was a year it might
have been my like second album promo run
or something
i don't remember it was probably 0.607
it was it was noah's after yeah after
the ray happened
yeah it was like right after maybe it
was like super bowl was out there or
something that's what it was
yeah it was a super bowl because i
remember that it was like a couple years
maybe right after that but yeah man like
that moment when you got
you got raided and you you got arrested
you got arrested
well you didn't get arrested were you
around that no i'm not gonna tell you
crazy it's crazy though
i was on my way to the studio i was in
the car with freeway we were actually on
our way here and mind you we weren't
just like we were we've been friends
since
college but it's not like we saw a lake
every day so right
let's put that in perspective right so
this is a day that i was actually about
to come over today just so happen to be
coming over there yeah we're gonna pull
up i don't know if we were working on a
mixtape or working on something but
we're gonna stop over there
and uh remember mace was there the night
before because i
brought mace over there the night before
and we had actually took pictures to do
a mixtape
wow that never came out mace
and drama yeah yeah and uh
we drove by and we saw that [ __ ] we kept
going
and uh honestly we thought it was
happening to the studio that was next
door
because it was a studio literally next
door to dram studio
and uh we thought that i was getting
ready so he was like man we're just
gonna keep it moving you know wow
we're riding too cool at the time either
yeah i feel like that's one of those
historical moments that kind of changed
so much
in in in you know in you know the
hip-hop culture man
and it kind of was like the the
beginning of the end of the mixtape era
yeah of the hour that's how we know it
for sure as we know it where you could
just pull up
i mean obviously you know things were
changing it's interesting looking back
on it because like
you know everything literally went
digital yeah after that it was straight
to the
the z share link and you had to download
and then that piff came along
and then i also feel like after that the
change really came
in like how artists were putting
mixtapes out because
you know you got to think about right
after that that's when like whiz and
cole and kendrick and drake and
yeah they all were like it was all
original music but they were still like
mixtape forms so yeah
they were still technically mixed in
count against their deals yeah like that
was like
i feel like what happened with you guys
kind of kicked off that whole era of
almost like it was the mixtape era and
then the blog era blogging right yeah
the blogs became the new mixtapes
yeah so when you get arrested and you
get rated
like what what's the thought process man
and and did you have any idea that that
could be
that that could happen nah i really
didn't i never in a million years would
have thought that i mean one because we
were like
we felt like darlings of the industry in
a lot of ways like we were
we're hot like it was i was on fire you
know what i'm saying and like
you know we were also in bed with
so so much of the music industry with
all the labels
not only from being djs but then you
know from labels were paying for
gangster grills and
you know i had an album deal with
atlantic at the time so
um when it when it all went down it was
like
yeah our minds were blown like i in a
million years never like you said
i thought they were coming for the
studio next door on some [ __ ] i didn't
think they was coming to get me and even
when it
we first like went through the motions
it i didn't comprehend it you know
and um it's so weird because there's so
many like
different theories or or
reasons how and why it happened you know
what i mean but um
it regardless it changed the whole game
and like it literally changed the game
overnight you know what i'm saying and
the mixtape game was totally different
after that and
you know it you know it was the top of
the food chain so a lot of [ __ ] who
was doing what we were doing were like
yo if they
go get drama and then i'm like no i
remember they got like big mike
and they got they got some yeah some
guys back then yeah um
but not like that no one's i don't feel
like anyone's situation they made an
example of you guys because you were the
biggest
yeah like it was just it was crazy so
but i mean and
you know it also made us
more famous than ever you know so it was
like it's
it kind of set up for the first gangster
girls album and
um yeah so i mean you know looking back
on and it's like
who knows how [ __ ] would have played out
in our careers if that may not have
happened but
um but you know another part of it too
was like i
i felt a lot of guilt at first when that
[ __ ] happened because i felt like
damn this [ __ ] like this here's a
culture that i like grew up
like loving and like you know you're the
guy yeah i'm like damn this shit's gonna
die on my shoulders like
i felt terrible for for a minute you
know what i'm saying so i remember even
when i
like first did against the girls or like
when did the tape when me and wayne did
dedication three
it was like i can't let this [ __ ] down
on you know on my dime like you know i'm
letting all the guys who came before me
down so
to see where quote-unquote mixtapes are
now today or just even
because i feel like they really it was a
phoenix that arose from now like
if you look at it now in whatever form
mixtapes are bigger business than they
ever were
you know what i'm saying well yeah now
they're they're modded they're fully
monetized 100
in the artist's favor you feel what i'm
saying so you know um
i do miss like the energy of like you
know it was the remixes and the
freestyles and [ __ ] yeah and and it was
it was just different and now it's like
even when people drop
mixtapes to a certain degree unless you
get all your
your um everything cleared like it's
just you know with all due respect to
the mixtape sites is
you everyone wants to be on all the dsps
like i don't even know
what i'm saying i still haven't even
like tapped in with the wayne tape
because i'm just i'm not downloading no
like i'm like you know like
because it's not on the dsp yeah like i
wanted to be another time we were doing
it it was like
everyone there would we there were no
dsps so it was like you
everyone had to have whatever gangster
girls yeah so back then right give me
the process so you do it gangster grills
and for people who don't kind of
understand like how tapes circulated
back then
and kind of what you got like you were
actually like were you wholesaling tapes
out from
your headquarters yep yeah we still
selling them out from the headquarters
and then we was um
we had a whole system shot my man jason
brown um
we would uh wholesale them out from the
studio then
you know also the mixtape sites would do
what they do and then who knows what the
bootleggers was doing so they
you know from canal so like a mixed unit
was like a big site right would mix
units
buy stuff straight from you yeah they
would they'll buy streaks was that clint
sparks website
uh-huh clinton yeah because i always
wondered like
it's you know the whole idea of a
mixtape is kind of bootleg anyway right
but then you would kind of know when you
get like the official joint because it'd
have like the back black writing on it
and
on the cd right yeah word how you you
kind of know you know what i'm saying
yeah yeah yeah yeah for sure so you guys
would you guys just kind of had your own
little
distribution system we was killing [ __ ]
actually it was crazy crazy yeah it was
like um
what was your like a like a wholesale
like if if if if somebody like what were
you selling your tapes were
like it was like like two dollars
it would vary from like two dollars to
four dollars depending on where
you know where the market was that's
crazy yeah and yeah i mean that [ __ ] i
know how cheap it is especially you know
you guys probably had
25 cd burners going yeah and it'll
probably cost us like
30 cents a cd or something like that
trying to think of the cost
man used to go on that back room interns
would be back there
putting them cds together like new jack
city bro just
like packaging them joints up there they
have boxes filled
oh man used to be able to go back there
i remember i used to go back there
whenever i needed all of it i just go
back there and get the 25 hottest new
mixtapes because he was doing
they was doing one every other week
between them three between him since and
canon
yeah there was one coming out every week
so you go over there you got applies
tape and
every genre from you know you got a joe
budden mixtape
would you would you guys wholesale other
people's tapes for them
no only affiliate we only did a few only
affiliate sheets yeah
interestingly enough i don't know if you
know this but
so back in the day
we wound up um meeting kanye very early
on
and we wound up getting some drops from
him um
he was on tour with uh quality at the
time uh yeah yeah and we also my man
damien lemon used to work at um
vibe magazine so he had his he had
kanye's college dropout
super early super super early so we had
a copy of the album
and then joe button was on um
was on his promo runs when um pump it up
first came out
and we had we had we got joe button to
host the tape so at the time i mean
cannon was like uh
cayenne and joe button didn't really
feel gangster girlish at the time
i was like we need another we need
another mixtape series like what should
we call it
and we call it a generation now wow
actually i remember burning those cds
and it was like almost like a tape that
had just a bunch of new [ __ ] on it
generation now yeah i used to burn those
yeah and that was our side tape
something didn't fit and like i had all
y'all's names on it right mm-hmm yeah i
remember those
damn fools so that's how long that's how
long we've had the name damn
yeah so canon talk about how you and
drama initially linked up
like your guys's history uh we linked up
in college a good story because i went
to
i used to uh kick it with my man jabari
harris
all right and jabar is one of my closest
people in philly he wasn't coming to
atlanta to school and i was
he was like yo when you get down there
it's a kid named dram he's
dope you need to get with him he's
already with the roots and
and um and bahamadi and just working
with him shout out to muhammad
man shout out to bahama and uh he was
like you make beats y'all should hook up
and my whole
thought process is like he next to the
roots all about the quarters
beats you know what i was saying so i
came to school i met him on the pronoun
one time and i and i gave him some beats
and i think he took it home
and he came back was like yo you beat's
hard you need to come by the crib
and you know and work on some [ __ ] and
we just we went to the crib
and worked on some stuff i think he was
you know uh rest in peace to jackson
um and them guys beats his records
but he was just like flooding my beats
to people you know what i mean
he was like actually he was the form he
was my manager
i remember like you know right and at
that time he was making beats also
if you could find that 32 beat cd
that's a classic if you find his 32 bcd
but uh yeah
he was making beats i was making beats
and we was just we was just kicking [ __ ]
man
it was times where i i i actually got
kicked out of school right and i ain't
telling my mom
she knows now but i got kicked out of
school and i ain't had no place to live
and he kind of took me in
like you know for a little bit and i
would go back and forth between him as
uh trent said i had a duplex and i would
go back a fourth day crib if i got on
his nerves
you go over there vice versa so until i
got my
you know my stuff together so you know
we we went to the club he was djing
clubs i started going to club with him
and you know taking the craze and just
filling in doing different things
and also uh you know when we was making
the mixtapes we just was you know
putting the stuff
together at the crib um it got
you know it was just his his crib was
the hub i keep saying uh
532 glen iris like that was the hub it
was just the shack where
you know he had a nice little room any
and everybody was in there t.i was
rapping in the bathroom
scrappy came by lil john came by anybody
you think of two chains
changes monica you know what i mean wow
it just was in this crib
and it was just a place to be so i
wouldn't want to be nowhere else he had
the records he had like a whole wall
of records you know i was saying dusty
little crib too
yeah it was it wasn't the best
everything no it's not even like a nice
condo or nothing like
it's dusty she was in the hood yeah he
did it was in the fourth floor we eat
good you know we eat good go to music
until it's time to you know disperse and
you know and play our role with those
you know
yeah so you uh obviously start as a
producer
you're i always say this you're like one
of the most fire producers thank you bro
appreciate it thank you yeah
um did did like drum convince you to
start
doing the mixtape thing as well or was
that something that just kind of
naturally happened um
i actually i started djing when i was
five years old okay so you
were you are already djing as well yeah
so i grew up wanting to be shaq
you know what i mean when i was 11 i
wanted to be in the nba and make beats
i was a rapper first and then i was
making beats shaq better point guard
than chris ball
[Laughter]
no doubt no doubt yeah but uh and then
in high school how i used to make my
money i was making mixtapes my
first dj name was the last don oh wow
and i used to just
you know make i think they leaked iron
man
uh ghostface early oh wow and i was like
the first person to put on my mixtape so
i had that
uh some underground dudes like elder
head toucher and all that stuff and i
used to put them on tapes
and i used to just move them through
high school because that's how i made
money i was the hustler in high school
so even if people owe me money i would
just get like
you know they'd bring their khakis i'd
sell the khakis to somebody or shoes but
the tapes was the main thing but then
when i got to atlanta i was like yo
i need to get on some producing i mean
but the djinn came so wild because i was
dj on campus
a couple guys saw me was like yo you
need to come do chili pepper
and all these clubs and when i did those
clubs they was like yo you dope as hell
dj and i just got gigs so it just
started falling in place
but um we started we started rocking
together and it was like it was
sometimes where drama was getting so hot
on the mixtape game
that i was doing a lot of the gigs you
know what i'm saying he was just so high
he at a point i think he was like i
don't even [ __ ] with the clubs like that
no more i'm just
you know i'm over here right and i just
did a lot of the gigs you know what i'm
saying
could somebody was doing tapes and and i
was doing tapes too like
in the early years like and i'm not even
talking about like i'm talking about
even when i was in college
right okay okay cause i used to i used
to set up on campus
canada did the tape called the after
party i remember j donnie
yeah that's the that was my college yeah
you know i mean so i used to like hustle
r tapes are myself and yeah
yeah they are him and transgender i get
him credit for me using my real name
my whole life i ain't like my name you
know what i'm saying so they was like yo
can on
nice like oh my god it's just whack
it turned out you know what i'm saying
but i didn't like it for a long time but
you know i credit them for doing that
you know in philly for some time now
canon has been like a a name people like
what's up canon
but even before we was telling before
that happened we was telling him like
yeah they would never call me by my name
it was like canon yeah they wouldn't be
like
donnie brasco this is like whack fire
name like
yeah why would you not hey do you
remember the like the beat that um
like kind of changed your uh like kind
of changed
your life as a producer what oh man
crazy yeah i could say i could say go
crazy but the one that i get the
most accolades from the most
people i would never thought i'd ever
speak to was canon luanne yeah and that
was
the reason why is like i went acro when
i started traveling bro i was running
into everybody like
premier and all these people and it was
like yo i need to holler at you
and i was like yeah like when you made
that beat right
like was your um
like drop like like like did you make
that beat like or did you add that later
like what was the
process of that record with wayne i'm
gonna tell you a story so
so this is how it came about when i uh
when i did go crazy um
nr from atlantic i forgot his name at
the time but he was like yo i want you
to go work with trick daddy
in uh florida no orlando did it no no it
wasn't orlando i was on holland
okay my phone was this guy you forget
his name but uh
i went to miami and i went to circle
house and i was busting my brain on what
i could make trick daddy that feel like
me
and miami at the same time so at that
time i was like come on ride this train
was like you know a southern base
record and i was like yo i'm my east
coast to [ __ ] out
and how wanda flipping it um
trick that didn't really like it you
know he was working on a madonna record
at the top
what the [ __ ] yeah it was like trick
that he was going to strip club every
day from like 11
in the morning to like six and a half
madonna it was
i think if madonna was on a hook or
something it was something that's why
some huge [ __ ] i think trick was huge
huh he was popping yeah no trick was
crazy so my whole thing was like i loved
trick as a rapper i was like damn i just
wish he could come in the room
and be like yo i don't like this but i
like that but it just ain't work out
that way but i wind up
leaving the stuff there but it was a
dude uh fiend that was there
i don't know if you know fiend no limit
yes yeah fiend was just damned
today yeah he was he's a phenomenal
writer so he was like
coming in the second left loving
everything i was [ __ ] with he was
like bro i love that
he was the first person to do a canon
hook he went on there and was like
i got the a k i'm with the canon that
was
he was the first person to use the drop
it didn't go all the way through like
everybody but he was like yo i got it a
k with a cannon and i was like oh that's
fire but
it never amounted to nothing so i wound
up taking the record back home
i think i gave it to him first now
yeah you gave it to buster no remember
because orlando gave it to beau higgin
bohegan had it first yeah boy you
remember of course
and then after that it was buster and
then busting tip
buster i don't think both higgins did
canon though i think he wrapped on it
but he didn't do the
layout he might not have he didn't have
to be yeah buster did the layout yeah
buster did it
buster had it first yeah he went dumb
yeah you know what i'm saying yeah
because there was different
iterations of that record i remember
yeah he went dumb and then uh he wound
up giving it to wayne and then
wayne just went stupid the craziest
thing is people don't know is
wayne wrapped the whole three minutes
long we had to make the verses because
he just wouldn't stop
so he just he just is in this in the in
the booth he wrapped the whole thing
straight
i still got that version too yeah yeah
so i was going to miami
it was when cali was shooting holla at
me okay and
everybody went to miami for that video
and we were ju
that he dedication i was gonna go to
circle house to go pick up
dedicate that's crazy because that's
where the beat was made too but i was
going to circle house to go pick up the
music for dedication too
and um uh it was that same night and
then i went over there and i was like yo
i got this
just beat my man-made like to see if you
[ __ ] with it for the tape and that was
the last song he did
for dedication too and he was spazzed
and like the next day gave it back to me
yeah that was that was the whole making
of that and people don't really know
that story but i tried to tell that
story because that was like
a magical mistake you know when i was
making that record it was like oh
go crazy was the same way when i made go
crazy
it was for artists we had named willie
the kid oh shout out willie the kid yeah
shout out to willie yup shout out to
willie and i think i was making it
watching dead president was that y'all's
first artist
yeah okay okay yeah and and i i wind up
um giving it to him and t.i wrapped on
it but he didn't
i wound up giving willie another beat
because we couldn't get it right some
something happened we couldn't get that
record right for him so i gave him
another beat and then that went to dram
and you know and that's yeah go go crazy
uh
is one of those ones man it's like
how crazy was it when you heard jay-z's
remix about to say his first beat out
the gate
holes on the roof it was crazy because
i remember coach k like yo got something
for you
got something for you i'm like man
whatever whatever you talking about
i thought i didn't know what it was
going i thought it was going to be like
a jeezy and a couple other people that
you know and and uh when he said jay-z i
said all right i'll wait to hear it when
i believe it
and to this day uh i think jay-z
performed it at birthday before birthday
bash i forescan in the car yeah and i
had i wouldn't come
but i came like you know bro i loafed my
bread in my throat
when i heard i seen all the people i
said oh [ __ ] that's real
yeah you know what i mean because i
didn't know what i was doing at the time
we were just
he was having fun yeah i mean it was
just everything we did was fun
you know what i mean damn that's crazy
man yeah that record is like
one of those ones it's like i remember
like
first time i pressed play on that cd
that was the one record
cause i'm like like a boom bap hip hop
head and that record was like
it was like hearing gz in a different
light yeah that was one thing that i did
strategize i was like yo
cause go crazy original had brick b
drums on it
and i was like how can i get this sound
and him together to make it that and i
always wanted to
sit in front of like him and jay in the
conversations like yo what did you hear
jeezy do that one made you want to do 64
bars of
classic verse because i you know jay
does a verse he does some special verses
but that one was just long it was
different you know what i'm saying so i
was just trying to figure out like
what did gz say on there that made you
like oh man i got to go crazy like you
know what i'm saying so
i just i just you know going through
that whole
proc that that whole process was was fun
because we were
we was just doing us i don't think we i
mean
we had objective to make money but i
think at that time i was just
happy to be a part of facts you know
what i mean yeah for sure
um back then like when like gangster
girls are hot as [ __ ] right
could a label pay you to do it like like
let's say it was an artist that was
you didn't know about could they cut the
stimulus check most of it and he did
plenty of times
you gotta think too at the time i mean
it may be a little different now but
even there are artists
like yogaty's an example of that like
the first tip we did together
he paid me and he was he had just got
signed so these are still artists that
are
like you know we know of today you know
what i'm saying that the labels were
still cutting checks for
so it would it would vary like they
would come from all
avenues would you about to ask though no
i was going to say what what was the
biggest
uh what like what's the like what was
the the going rate um
it got up to like 25 30 000.
damn like a tape yeah i was crazy yeah
and then like
so give me like so like so something
like the little brother gangsta grills
right
which was so dope because one of my
little brothers obviously from the south
right but they kind of you know it's
crazy because back then
i feel like we really separated types of
hip hop hundred percent
so much more than we do now yeah they
told me it wasn't gonna make sense when
i did that
like now like people can work with each
other and
people don't even bat an eye at it back
then like i like remember like how how
crazy it was like
when you heard talib quality and jay-z
on a song together absolutely
like and so you know there's a lot of
that yeah yeah kanye had a lot to do but
you doing the gangster girl's a little
brother right was that your idea was
that the label coming
in no that had nothing that was me and
little brother i mean i was
i had been a fan like i'm we're hip-hop
heads too so
you know what i'm saying i've been a
little brother fan and when
i remember we wound up we ran into each
other they had a show at yin yang cafe
here in atlanta and i went to go see him
and we we talked about it on the bus and
and it's
looking back on it like again little
brother tape and the pharrell tape
like when i did those tapes crazy like
though at the time gangster girls was
still known
for like t.i gz wayne bunby so it was
it had a certain you know style to it or
it was like
street music you know what i'm saying so
i remember people being like you're
going to do a gangsters with who
little brother pharrell and i was like
watch this and you know
like even for me like that was getting
back to my roots to be able to do
something with them you know what i'm
saying so
they they you know them being a fan and
me being a fan it was like it was
it was perfect like i was so excited to
do those tapes too to really just start
branching out and going
different directions too with the brand
yeah and then like how many like so okay
like you mentioned the um the pharrell
tape which is [ __ ]
so fire cannon actually ghost dj that
hole too oh you did okay okay
but i'm just curious like he was on the
road
uh questionable i have questionable
turntables
you and uh pharrell like you decided to
do against the grills does he just
handle all the creative or are you
sending him
ideas beats it was both we sending him
ideas and beats and
um he was he had a phenomenal
uh uh outline of where he wanted to go
with it he definitely picked some
incredible beats and we gave him
some and um you know and i what i used
to do is i used to write out a script
i used to have a script and it basically
was like literally like me interviewing
the artist
and that would kind of give me a formula
for the tape so you know that's what i
used to do interludes and
chop it up you know just kind of piecing
those stuff that stuff together like um
so so yeah i mean and again you know i
met i met pharrell
when tip was on house arrest um like
before we did down with the king
so we had we had got acquainted then
you know so he was familiar with me
early on in my like
in that part of my career so then you
know he kind of touched back and was
like yo
i love what you're doing like we got to
do one i mean to this day it's the only
mixtape he's ever done you know and it's
just you know it's being fan like it was
monumental
like i know that that's just that's a
tape too like
you know i meet a lot of kids today and
not even kids anymore but you know
they'll be like yo that pharrell gang
like
the same way like uh the jeezy and a
weighing tape is to
to some that's how you know a different
uh cloth is to the
to the pharrell tape percent you know
what i'm saying so yeah all classics we
got nothing but [ __ ] classics under
our belts
yo we're uh breaking down this video
we're not breaking it down we're taking
a break in the video
to tell you all about our sponsors odd
socks all right listen man uh
oddssocksofficial.com
what the [ __ ] was that bro uh it was
like a [ __ ] pomeranian hair floating
in air
anyway odd socksofficial.com keyword
bootleg kev
go over there get you some socks and
you'll save 20 off if you use that
keyword they got south park
license they got some ghostbusters pimp
c
mike tyson really the one that i really
care about is they got that wwe license
you can get these awesome nwo socks
and then they got their odd socks basics
you know for all the basic [ __ ] get
you some basic socks
even though they are very comfortable uh
they're probably the most comfortable
socks
actually not probably definitively the
most comfortable socks i've ever put on
my feet
yes all right and that goes for all
types of socks
so go to oddssocksofficial.com get some
socks by the way
spongebob socks they're kind of fly
right christmas time's on the way
use the keyword boulet kev 20 off
oddssoxoficial.com
support us by supporting odd socks let's
go um
when was like when did you realize
or like you guys as a crew like that
gangster grills was like
the brand
um like i know that like the early tapes
but like what was the one like like the
one that like like do you remember that
moment where you were like
it was levels it was a lot i mean
yeah it were levels because
[ __ ] i think about like gangster girl
six we had like
bone crusher david benner killer mike
hosting it was like
we wound up seeing nothing but boo like
when 50
when give richard not trying came out we
wound up finding his like bootleg
spot in the tuck in the west end and we
literally saw like
get richard trying's walls full and then
gangsta grill six walls full so
it's almost like flattering they
bootlegged your [ __ ] 100 like it was the
most flattering thing ever we i was
ecstatic um so then there was that level
then there was like
the ti down no the ti meets gangsta
girls
uh in the streets was literally the
first
tape that was just one artist you know
before that it was like compilation
it was a mixtape so then it was that
level that we knew okay or something i
remember
you know them even tell i remember we
went to like make show power summit that
year
and i was thinking about taking more of
my neo soul tape than i was
they'd get the tip tape and sensing
candle like [ __ ] bugging like [ __ ] are
you talking about
um that's just how hype i was just on
the automatic like a whole nother series
i had but right right right right
then there was um i can't even imagine
you like talking your [ __ ] over
automatic relaxation here's some trivia
what was the first gangster girl
not the first gangster girls tape what
was the first name
um how was it jim crow laws that was one
and then how the south was one that's
another yeah the south was one
that's when we knew it was like oh yeah
okay
yep you get upset because from the
college day yeah because it was moving
like that was our first soft tape
and then obviously the tip down with the
king
that was a that was a big tape that
started garning some more attention that
was you couldn't go nowhere
especially in atlanta night is that the
one that um at jack and for beats on it
yeah that was one of the high jackets
for beats on it yeah jack and the beats
that's that's still my favorite that's
like peak t.i
emceeing right there he was going crazy
and then
gz um um what's the
streets is watching the first jeezy tape
and i was like
you know jeezy before jeezy was jeezy
gangster girls was gangster girls so
you know it was that tape was like the
first of its kind where it was like it
was an artist that
no one was really familiar with compared
to like tip tape or bum b
tape that came before that and then
obviously like trapper dies like the
world changed like everything was
different so
so yeah i would say going up to that
level that was
those couple tapes to figure it out
initially um
doing that first tape with jeezy was
that like um did you guys have an
organic relationship
was it like was how did that like
how did that initially start so the
house the crib that he's talking about
532 glen iris in the fourth ward um
our neighbor around the corner was coach
k
okay so we met coach um when we moved
into the neighborhood
and he befriended us early and we
befriended each other
he had this group called jadis um bobby
creek water was actually in the group we
wound up
signing right to shady yup um
and then you know we were all
pulling slick puller oh for real oh okay
so stick with me
yeah yeah he was one of the original
rappers too
so then we um you know coach was telling
us about
you know just this new artist he had and
jeezy's
first project was actually called come
shop with me and he had this video yeah
i remember seeing that he's like in the
jersey
jersey i remember buying it from when he
used to sound like trick daddy wow
and then so we knew so yeah it was it
was
pretty organic um you know he came he
came to me and we like
we met at this restaurant called harry
and sons and you know we um
he pretty much showed me it told me his
whole vision like this you know
the streets is really [ __ ] with your
drawing like you know i don't even know
if you realize how much the streets is
[ __ ] with you and
you know he told me it's the movement in
the campaign and
um yeah it was it was def it was really
organic i mean even
interestingly enough you know it's
atlanta too so you know lake was running
into carbon 15
um early in the game
yeah telling me yeah i got my man jeezy
and i'd be like huh like what are you
talking about
drama be telling me about it i actually
i actually met named two in a different
occasion i was in my dorm
and i used to have a window and my sit
up my dj set up and
produce and said i was in a window and
he used to uh come and
mess with this shorty that was my
next-door neighbor and he ran out my
window one time
and he was like you're making me fine
you know what i'm saying give me some
beats but it never
turned into nothing because i you know
we wanted to meet him a little later
he always reminds me of that by the way
but i knew you said he was making
beats of your [ __ ] dorm [ __ ] that's
crazy did say that not too long ago i
remember
yeah he reminds me i can't remember what
he was talking about yeah i remember
seeing him he's always had bread and i
was like
who's this cat bro and i used to look
like i used to come out the door and i
looked
again he had like this 645 some crazy
[ __ ]
okay that he's something yeah you know
that costs money yeah yeah we wound up
seeing
him a little later and i was like okay
that's the dude and and he used to come
to club envy all the time too
oh yeah that's right his record played
that trip daddy record yeah
yeah he used to break bread to get that
record playing yeah listen for a long
time what's the craziest uh
bmf party or event you guys i've i've
heard stories about these parties that
are
legendary insane what's the craziest
thing each birthday
yeah nothing nothing's [ __ ] with it
to this day
matt there was a magic city party where
i i literally saw regular women turn
into
strippers like shot the hannah kang for
blowing that party was crazy yeah
he used to have like animals hannah put
that together the invitation remember
you you
opened it up and it talked to you it was
like like a diploma like it came wrapped
like in the diploma you opened it up and
then
i think it was blue da vinci like yeah
come to hang with big me to the jungle i
was like what happened
what was there it wasn't walking in the
direction tigers were right there it was
giraffes
yeah there was all types of [ __ ] yeah
they got giraffes there yeah
she had everything yeah that was a
legendary time i mean just even
you know like and we're talking about
one of the
craziest but like just on a regular
night of visions on a tuesday or was it
thursday whatever the night or
both of them you know them [ __ ] would
literally come in and be like
50 100 deep and everyone would have a
bottle like yeah
this is like early it was just a
different time like nothing
was like that error you know yeah i
remember one specific time i was djing
off night and i think um
it was what'd it do pimping i think it
was uh
either jeezy jeezy and bumby and one
night i played it and it was like every
time you play that joint you're gonna
put a hundred dollars on the table
man i think i left for thirty five
hundred i'm not even lying
oh i'm not i think yeah fact every time
it was like this every time i ran it
back they was just dropping it like this
and i was like oh [ __ ] this is real yeah
i'm saying
hope y'all like this [ __ ] song
i was making i probably was making 250
dollars yeah
for the whole night the first time yeah
the first time i ever saw any real money
was
because of bmf like an mla trip
no no but even before the la trip um
uh i was doing gangster girls
i think it's still when it was like
regular mixtape and i asked blue da
vinci like yo do you want to sponsor a
tape like you know i put a song on put
your logo on and everything
he was like like how much i was like
like you know like eight you know i mean
something he was like hey i got it's no
problem i'm thinking 800
you know he literally takes me to a crib
and gives me eight grand like
i'd never seen that type of money i that
[ __ ]
i had that eight grand for like i
literally had the cash and i had it in
my closet maybe for about a year
you know i'm still making okay money but
never where i had gotten
that eight grand chunk of money at one
at one time it was like
it ballin blew me away yeah it was a
shot to those guys man shot the blue
shunt
shout out to me shout out to t you know
i mean it was just a
it was it was it was a special time in
atlanta i i and correct me if i'm wrong
y'all but isn't
isn't that the era where throwing money
in the air comes from yes absolutely
absolutely right comes from absolutely
from that era like and if it didn't i'm
gonna give it to him cause i i've been
in so many
like dj in strip clubs where it was
piles of money this high bro i've never
seen nothing like that him jd
nelly them they all it was different it
was different bro what which
was different what did people do in the
strip clubs before we made it rain like
i i don't even remember like how did the
transaction go dances like
dances i suppose yeah like it changed
the whole culture in the west coast we
not
you know we come from a culture where
it's like we're not throwing nothing you
know at all you know
like it's it's amazing couple dollars
being thrown but what they used to do
like the briefing cases and trash bags
like come on that [ __ ] was
actually was bad thing was already
legendary
wow that's crazy legendary so um
obviously generation now you guys is a
flagship artist uzi
yeah um he's from your hometown um
how did you guys meet uzi i remember um
the first person that put me on to him
was
was it was either will from taylor gang
or ty
sounds about right yeah so it sounds
about right yeah
i think it was ty i think it was in
boston with ty and we're in his room and
he was just playing [ __ ] off soundcloud
i was like what is this
that came from us being on tour and with
those guys shout out to those guys so
ty's actually the first one that gives
you a show mm-hmm oh wow
like a real pace show in l.a his first
show you want to hear some crazy [ __ ] in
2015
i had a birthday show that burner was
supposed to headline in phoenix
and bernie couldn't show up and will was
like look man
do you want me to get who's do you want
me to try to get uzi to do it
and at the time i was like i don't know
if these people would give a [ __ ] who
little uzi is
right because they were there it was
like a real like it was like burner and
boz from dream it was like some rap [ __ ]
right i was like i was like i'll pass
like like don't make the call you know
what [ __ ] idiot i am crazy but but
not but like
how did you guys initially find uzi uh
candy can't take this off
uh i was working at def jam i was vice
president
nr and uh i wind up
a lot of people don't notice when i was
trying to dj i was trying to transfer
over
and doing edm dj and wise and i got
connected with this guy named sujit
and yes and scam he represented me for
about a year and some change
and he had me and just incredible you
know i seen just incredible
[ __ ] billboard i mean i was just like
holy [ __ ]
this is crazy so i i was like y'all want
to get in this circuit he was like i
don't put you on that same circuit so i
i started doing houston vegas and
atlantic city
my first atlantic city gig i think it
was at mgm or something
uh i had to drive i had to fly in the
philly and drive to
atlantic city and when i drove to
atlantic city
i turned on the radio and i was
listening to diamond cuts yeah
um diamond cuts is a different story too
because i used to dj for miss jade
and when i didn't go on the road with
miss j anymore i seen diamond cuts one
time i was like yo you should
take over what i'm doing you know what i
mean
and so when i'm driving down there she's
playing just in the mix show and i heard
a song it's called the real uzi
and i was like yo this sounds special
what is this i call her immediately like
yo who was that
she was like yo it's just artists i'm
working with nate uzi vert i was like yo
i come back from lancaster i want to
meet him time went by i didn't get a
chance
um but the next time it's like next time
you're in philly come
up uh what's another weird situation i
lived in
you know this area called east falls is
right off of ridge avenue they had a
next door uh kind of little city called
many young and i went home
and i was like i wanna meet this kid
he's probably in north philly somewhere
somebody basement recording some crazy
[ __ ] right
he's like yo darren man young so i was
like oh [ __ ] that's
walking distance from the cribs i went
to manhunt went to the studio
um listened to some songs he was in the
studio just silent as a [ __ ]
acting like he know
i was just you know he was just being
him
his guy uh i forget the manager name
damn
what's this man okay buzz was there he
was just you know speaking for him
he just kept playing me crazy records
and i was like oh this [ __ ] crazy
so i go back to atlanta i tell them like
yo we could do this [ __ ] again because
at the time
we wasn't really doing no record label
stuff drama was building the studio
he was like i want you to see some [ __ ]
down below you guys had you know went
down that road before
yeah we did the affiliates yeah and then
uh i i went to la
was trying to figure some things out
moved there for like 18 months didn't
like it
came back home but me and john started
communicating he was like yo i want to
show you something you get back to
atlanta
i came he was building uh mean streets
uh
501 which is now the famous 501 main
streets and i uh
and i seen it and i was just i went in
the studio and he was asking me about
equipment i was like damn you got to get
this right mike and
you know i mean no speakers we could do
that and you know he had a radio room
and everything was getting built out and
it was just special so i was like damn
as we started working and
i was i was coming to the studio more
regularly when he was doing stuff
and i was like yo i found this kid we
need to do this [ __ ] i'm telling you
this [ __ ] gonna work
right and then we was like [ __ ] we all
in we never really told each other no on
nothing
right but he was like yo this gonna win
and this is like our first time like
as the three of us because we're always
like making
drums relationship and ours was
different me and lake would meet up and
talk forever he would
get me so much money on the mixtape side
just hosting and
he would bring freeway over to the crib
and stuff like that and then
he was doing some stuff so we all
combined it you know what i mean and
then we we finally got uzi to atlanta
and i think his first he recorded in
january
he never left he just stayed i'm not
going back home
you know what i mean so that's how the
whole play came together and then we
just worked on it from there it was just
you know what was like the like was the
carnage record like his first like big
look yeah
yes yeah yeah because i remember that
record like
just going up in the club and and and
that really being like i had heard the
name because of like
a whale but i was like oh [ __ ] this [ __ ]
is yeah when i speak about conviction
think about it when i was talking to him
and trying to get him into the fold
he was already talking to asap yams
already he was uh
kanye was interested through this kid
named charlie heath
charlie heat was working with kanye he
was trying to bring him there
um he sat loved him
uh rich the kid and him was get
it was in like a little space so it was
like you know it was a lot going on
at that time you know while we was
trying to figure out how he was going to
do the deal
we still had a name i think we waited
like six months trying to figure out
what the name of the company was going
to be
yeah we did we was just like they said
anything just sign him and let's go we
didn't you know
it was just a tough just trying to
figure it all out because it was so it
was so sudden
you know i mean even at that time i was
trying to even though we was doing it i
was going to take our situation and try
to do it through def jam and that didn't
work out because it was just so much
going on
i brought so much talent to def jam to
just wind up not getting signed
that i just like yo it's time i learned
some stuff like who
uh i brought rich homie quan i mean uh i
told him about the amigos
i told him about iggy azalea very early
i uh i actually tried to sign asap rocky
in the asap mob and when i couldn't get
them because it was already getting
ready to get committed
i seen that uh iggy azalea was there she
had a song called [ __ ] it was like
2011.
i sent the email it's like nah you know
what i was saying
wind up getting signed later it was just
so much random [ __ ] that you know
i was just telling them about and it
just didn't work out uh there was
something like
we dirk and reese that there were some
that we kind of like nurtured right
um logic uh these are all the things
that we can
bring logically no oh my god noah
preston okay okay
but we all were like when we went to
cali was me him no id
we're all like a hub so we're just
bringing things in trying to work it
i think uh uh who was it
janae aoki we just had a mean team we
were like administration
so you know what i mean so when we were
we were doing all that i was learning so
much i was like yo we can do this
because i
already know how the buildings work you
know i mean we're in the building yeah
yeah
i i knew for three years i was like oh
man i learned so much let's just go do
this [ __ ] outside you know what i mean
and i was just almost certain you know
drama
to atlantic yeah it almost took like the
finding the right artist to like
you know well we had tried to sign a
couple other people yeah initially when
we first got going like
we took a couple trips and we we had
flown to see a couple people
and like we always had them like right
here and we would lose them at the last
minute and
that's why we were so adamant about the
oozy thing what did you anybody that we
would know that you want absolutely
yeah like i mean i think the first one
was ot genesis
we did playhouse with ot one night night
on ot from a while back and i ended up
dming him
and um i think i overslept and i didn't
end up checking my responses and when i
woke up and and checked the next day i
think busted already hollowed at him
so i tried this on tori trying to sign
tory lanez yeah we met with sasha early
in the game right at um
what's the name of the seafood spot oh
steam house steam house yeah game house
yeah i met with sasha about tory lanez
uh the amigos
yeah amigos wow she has tried to
so cause um let me
like i heard so was gucci the first
person to like kind of
find the migos or yes well yeah because
gucci
was already in business with them
i think like before he went to jail and
so you guys tried to sign them
prior to the qc thing happening it was
around the same time i mean
at the same time that i was like we were
in talks with them they were also
meeting with other people so
other there were other entities in
atlanta you know that were interested
and knew of them and everything but you
know i mean
we had a great rapport with them early
on like you know i i
you know cueva will tell you like the
first time they went he's been to new
york was
you know i took him up there for a
meeting um i had brought him out
on to birthday bad the first time doing
birthday bash was on my
set early on right so you know i mean
would definitely
you know see what those guys became you
know what i'm saying from those early
years but
but yeah so it was because of those
situations that we were like
um like yeah we you know let's let's we
can do this you know what i'm saying
y'all right
i just choked on up on a candy
yeah we had we true man and then
and then um yeah so i have been in
atlantic
as a a r maybe about a year and a half
already and you know i was kind of
trying to like find my way you know
kind of figured it out a lot differently
than me you know what i'm saying just as
far as like
you know how how i was going to maneuver
because atlantic was
was trying to put me in with um other
artists that were already on the label
right
and you know it was cool you know i'm
saying i had a good rapport but it
wasn't
you know we finally kind of when it was
time to renegotiate you know
they literally was like it was kind of
you know a little shaky and it was like
listen
you know they believed in me you know
they they knew that um
you know because of our rapport you know
i've been signing there as artists and
everything and
um just our relationships they're like
listen we want to give you another shot
you know what i'm saying let's let's
figure this out
you take me in the streets you guys you
know take uzi
and just like you know let's let you
guys figure out how you want to do it
instead of us trying to put something on
you
and we was like bet you know that was a
perfect situation for us off to the
races
yeah yeah so and then you know again
like you know i remember
the first time we met uzi was um when we
were on tour with uh whiz
and he uh we had a show in like philly
new jersey
area and he came to the show and um
first i remember first day he got on the
bus he
cracked on my jeans or some [ __ ] like
in classic uzi fashion you know said so
um but you know he always had that
energy and you know he
he always knew like you know he
definitely had a vision so
it was almost like he paid for some of
that [ __ ] but he didn't like when i when
i was in philly
i met him the first time meeting we in
south street he pulled up in his truck
as him and his cousin
big buff-ass cousin i'm like what they
think they about to beat me up or
something so we on the street
and he was like yo take a walk with me
so we walking we talking yeah i mean we
going different stores and they be like
oh that's the kid oozing i'm like yo no
way
i didn't know this kid it was very early
but they was like yo i [ __ ] with your
[ __ ] so
it made me do a little little
investigation and it was like he had
already been doing like little things
like beat battle i mean
rap battles and [ __ ] everywhere stuff
like okay that's how they know because i
was going to store they was like
slightly star struck a little bit this
is early
i'm like wait what's going on that's
what i knew i was like yo yeah like
they're already [ __ ] with them it is
crazy because
for a long time bro we always tried to
get
a philly artist you know i'm saying and
this just happened to be the time to
give them to the artist we've
everybody told us yo you got to get an
artist from yourself you got to get an
artist from the self
it was like yeah we're open to it and
that just fell in our laps
and somebody who's not like the
traditional and that's what's
what's even crazier about it is you know
obviously we all know
you know what philly um rappers
sounded like before that or or what you
know the perception was you know i'm
saying so when uzi came along and he was
just like
he was there was nobody else like him
especially from philly like
it was trying to grab me a water in
there dude i got like one right here i
got a half a damn cough drop stuck in my
[ __ ] throat
wherever those red candies were
yeah ugh much better jesus christ
anyway um i wanted to ask like
i just poured water on myself what is
the like current relationship with uzi
because you know i mean
everything's kind of been public that
there's obviously some disagreements and
you know what is your guys's current
relationship with him
he's signed a generation now um
he pretty much does his thing you know
and like
we support it and allow it and you know
i'm very proud of him yeah
yeah yeah i mean it's pretty much like
the basic you know like record label
artist situation
you know he's at a state where he likes
to kind of control his own creative
thing which he's always
you know been a part of other than canon
being super hands-on
and uh pretty much he controls the
timing the dynamic like
change between everybody like when like
like i mean obviously you know
i i feel like you guys kind of brought
him up in the game
right and then there's obviously a
disconnect that happened like it's
always human nature
you know i mean that that's what happens
you know you seen them
with the best you know dr dre and snoop
like there was no real problem
you know people put out there but it's
just like when you become an artist you
can
even be as a part car producer at some
point
when you have the success you'll be like
yeah i did this you know
i did this so you know i mean so i you
know i ran into those things where
you know honestly nobody know the story
in 2008
i was feeling myself and i kind of left
them out
yeah i remember that in the cold and i
was just like
you know obviously it was it was
something between us that
had nothing to do with them but it was
just like man i do i could do it on my
own [ __ ] it yeah yeah yeah i know
you guys had your like little paws in
y'all's relationship yeah and it was
just like it was
it was weird because this is funny
that's why i'm talking about it but it
was like we were throwing shots at each
other on
tapes and we would see each other and
everything cool
yeah i saw them like multiple times and
i just always thought when we see each
other it's gonna be
it's it's gonna be something you know i
mean i'm just with me it's me and my
cousin
it was 10 12 deep you know wow and we
were always cool we see each other and
it would it would be cordial
until you know me and dram just sat down
i was like
i think we used that jersey mics or
something yeah mice
and by the time we got this like what
are we even talking about it's just
nothing
you know what i'm saying so it always
happens with this stuff and you know as
you make music
uh things happen people want to do
things
i think with uzi 2 with our situation is
that
obviously on our end we would never have
wanted
any of it to play out in the public you
know i think a lot of
artists and record labels go through
similar situations
i feel like it's just kind of like a
generational thing like the first thing
when people get angry
what's a generational thing because of
social media right that's what i'm
saying yeah of course that's how they uh
express themselves that's how they
express themselves and you know from
on our end like you know we never you
know we never really even went on
a platform and you know defended
ourselves or you know anything like that
and
we just we didn't really want that you
know what i'm saying i mean obviously
one
we didn't want to be painted as no bad
guys you know what i'm saying but
i mean i'm sure the fan like his fans
are crazy right oh yeah it was it was
killing
social media i i had to take a pause you
know
thank you uzi like i definitely had to
like get off for a quick minute but you
know
i mean it's crazy just you know i don't
get any of that anymore but it's like
you know we wanted to
we've been in this business so long you
know our reputations are everything yes
of course so clearly
you know i guess more than anything you
know we let tom tell you know what i'm
saying and
you know morning like again he he's he's
family he's our artist so you know
we don't want anything but the best for
him you know what i'm saying
you guys want him to be you feel what
i'm saying so it was like for us we just
had to allow you know
we just had to let it play out and you
know fans are going to say what they're
going to say or people are going to
have their interpretation who don't know
us per se and you know it is what it is
like
i think did you guys get like a blunt of
the blame from fans for
eternal to take taking a blunt all of it
absolutely jesus
what was like the story as to why it
took so long like if you don't mind
getting into
it like what's the story or why did it
like why did it take so long was it was
it you know because i think that
there he literally put the album out
when he wanted to that's the craziest
part about everything like
i said when like you guys were holding
them up and i mean this
this is the most basic thing that i tell
everybody like we are in the business of
selling music you know what i'm saying
so there is no benefit to us
to hold anything of course not yeah it's
just not even logical you know what i'm
saying like we don't eat if music
doesn't come out
you know so like i don't know what power
struggle or what pride like would allow
us to even do something like that so
ultimately like
for real these guys put music out
sometimes they come to us two days
before
that used to be hannah's main play
because remember we came at the
transition
from the physical age to the digital
engine so i remember when cannon would
come to me and be like yo this kid wants
to put a project out
tomorrow and i'd have to clear 10 beats
you know and so on and so forth like
it's literally a feeling and when they
have the feeling like
they call me and [ __ ] has to come out
you know what i'm saying so we don't
really get any benefit
from like withholding or like
saying something can or can't come out
you know when it's ready we're ready for
that [ __ ] to come out too
yeah i mean like like he dropped pretty
much what two two albums and
you know back to back is that i
i wonder too because like you know
obviously your guys's kind of
situation is in public i i in my head i
thought is he trying to put out
like is he trying to get out of his deal
as quick as possible
because you know there's like draco dude
like drake you know did that with the
you know like like p artists have done
that you know
in in in the past like when when or is
it just the deluxe play because he kind
of
low-key looks play off yeah
yeah just i think he's just just a
deluxe play yeah i think it's just
something you want to get off and i
don't think he wanted to keep
both vibes in that name so it was like
one
one half of the album was kind of like
the first mixtape we edited
versus the world so he didn't want to
keep everything because
i think the eternal taki he just wanted
to have like this you know saying and
then
right right right it's just something
you know and then with jack like
your guy's a story finding jack because
you know if you saw jack harlow
uh when you guys first signed him you
know he doesn't scream like superstar
he looks like napoleon looks like yeah
he looks like like someone who works at
the geek squad at best buy or something
you know what i mean
and he's from louisville which is like a
place that's not known as like a talent
hub
right yeah i mean dram pretty much
really kind of steered that in the
direction but again when we all
met it's something that the guys have
in their eye and they and the way they
carried itself is like bro
that's gonna be some work but it's gonna
work you know what i mean and that's
we all see it we're like man we got to
do that one we got to it don't matter
what he looked like it just
it's the feeling it was the energy that
he had he already had a squad with him
his producer was dope as his producer
still is dope as hell
two for one you know it just was like it
just was there and it was like let's do
it
you know what i was in it didn't take
too much and it's hard to get these guys
to agree like so it's three of us right
and it's supposed to be two out of three
but really i'm usually just the guy
that's waiting to say yes right
right i bring a lot of stuff to the
table and it's hard as hell to really
convince
this guy and as hard as hell to convince
him too you know what i mean so
a lot of stuff that comes to the table
especially from our anr staff like it's
a lot of stuff that's shot down
so when we see something that we like
like we really attached
i can imagine like um the like
the success of what's popping had to
really like
it had to be sweeter than a lot of stuff
you guys have done before his generation
now
because i feel like at that time people
were kind of like well
you know with the oozy [ __ ] being out
there and then
you know jack harlow comes like what was
i mean is it triple platinum uh
yeah like that and the craziest part
about that record was i remember when
we played it in the music meeting and i
love i'd already heard it on spotify and
i love the record but it doesn't it
didn't have like it wasn't like a
traditionally formatted song
like when you first heard it you're like
wait i got to figure out where the hook
is type [ __ ]
but how like sweet was that like it
it almost was like a i felt like if i
was y'all i would have been like yeah
[ __ ] we did it again
we did at some point but we also like us
not staying in the public and doing too
much chitter chatter made it even more
sweet
absolutely never really came out and did
yeah it was just fun
let's keep working man just make some
[ __ ] yeah we still had the fun
in it and you know what i mean to make
it even better we have been working with
jack and he's been making these certain
type of songs
and we always say to him all three of us
yo you can rap
but he always like yeah i know but i
wanna i got this vibe i be like you can
rap
you know i'm saying so when that came
out it was like bro your first big
record
rapping you see what i'm saying and he
started out like that dark knight was a
rap record and
we just always stuck with that you know
what i mean so
that's what makes it sweeter that we
just put our head down and just kept
working
and it just popped up it wasn't like oh
we gotta hit y'all we ready it was just
like man we
rock and roll and again and i don't know
i i
you know sometimes i feel like you know
we've
maneuvered through our careers i don't
necessarily want to say
underdogs but feeling like yo like
this is what we do like we've been doing
this a long time we got to show you
again this is what we do
so i was like you know even through that
it was like again us not really
being vocal about it and just working
and you know having the results we have
it's like you know
like come on guys like duh we've been
telling you this for years that's what
we do
right right we're gonna keep doing it
you know what i'm saying so yeah i mean
it
obviously it was definitely like it was
it was a sweet feeling you know i'm
saying to
you know to come out through the year of
2020 and you know
have such a productive you know moment
for generation now
yeah like and i feel like too you know
like you said you guys kind of
started this with the transitional
period of
where music was and how it was consumed
and especially now right like
the playlisting [ __ ] is kind of crazy
yeah it's really like
yeah the gatekeepers of people's careers
real [ __ ] smaller real [ __ ]
you know what i mean like it used to be
like there was like 25 blogs that if you
could get on one like
four of them like you could really you
know now it's like you gotta
there's like this many people that
choose the like who's next you know what
i'm saying
i'm curious what would be some advice
you guys would give
um managers who are managing artists or
just young artists who are up and coming
trying to navigate their way who are
dope you know maybe have a little bit of
traction but just trying to navigate
their way through
the current musical climate because i do
feel like
the first thing every artist wants to do
is get on a playlist
and i'm not sure how like realistic that
is for everybody yeah that's hard
um that's a tough question because i
even when it comes to the playlist like
i'm you know i can only imagine what
it's like
you know coming from trying to make it
and you know
it's like you know damn near impossible
to get on playlist you know what i'm
saying
so to me i feel like the the the dsps
are the new radio
in in my opinion and i think um
the the first thing i would tell a young
man a journey young artist is is like
don't shortchange the process like i
think a lot of these kids everything is
so microwavable that they want
everything so fast like i get so many
dms every day like
how can you put me in contact with you
know a digital marketer that can get me
on rap caviar they're not asking to get
on
you know real estate down south and take
the steps up they want to take the leap
from where they
are directly to the top and you know i
say this all the time like
rap to me that's the only game that
really doesn't have a system of checks
and balances like
you know there is a kid that can
honestly make a song in his bathroom and
get on rap caviar but there's also a guy
that's been rapping for 15 years that
can't get him to catch him
you know so um what i would say is don't
short change the process for real
if you love it it's gonna show like the
guys that are the big guys the guys that
are the ones like that are consistently
the ones that we think about those are
the guys that put time and energy into
this [ __ ]
like the guys that you think play around
they don't like
as simple as you think uzi's music is
that kid literally
lived in the studio all day every day he
works on his melodies he thinks about
every concept
um another thing i would tell the kids
is is uh
you know and it's something that they've
actually created is is
you know i think you need to blend the
lifestyle with the music a lot of people
are attracted to the lifestyle before
the music so
i think that's something that uzi and
cardi playboy cardio does a lot of work
in here too
they they've gotten kids attracted to
the lifestyle you know yeah they're into
yeah they're into the personality the
person even more than the music
so that makes them fall in love with the
music and i think that's
that's the attraction that uzi's fans
have to his music it's almost like an
emotional attachment they feel like they
are him you know
they feel like they are that kid that's
going through the same emotional all
right so if you can make people care
about you
and make good music then you know it's
just a matter of time you just got to
make people give a [ __ ] about you
because like you said so many people are
making music right there's great music
that no we'll never hear because it's
it's hard to be relatable to have people
give a [ __ ]
about you yeah um drama i know you know
you just did the um
the black soprano family uh gangster
grills yes sir shout out to benny yeah
who's out here in atlanta now a lot um
how active are you trying to be like
still with you know doing
doing that kind of [ __ ] like i'm all for
it you know people
people come to me all the time like
either ask if i'm still doing tapes or
still show interest
in doing tapes you know so like i
i'd love that one was on the dsps yeah i
was on the dsps you know i just did one
with tiger
yeah you did do one with tigers that's a
gun intro yeah i was on yeah and shot
the west side gun i was on his album so
you know when it comes to tapes like you
know it's
i'm not going nowhere you know what i'm
saying this is what i do besides
you know i mean i'm as much as i'm an
executive ceo
you know label owner uh [ __ ]
studio owner i still go and dj somewhere
you know what i'm saying rock you know
what i mean so
um i i got some i got some more projects
coming this year actually
um that's going to surprise some people
when it comes to some tapes so i'm
looking forward to
to those he's being humble about that
too he's got some big [ __ ] [ __ ] got some
[ __ ] coming so you got
a new drink album i got some [ __ ] coming
okay get drake gangster girl's coming
yeah i would definitely do that
of course i'm all for that um uh he got
some [ __ ] yeah i got some [ __ ]
that's it um uh just randomly like i
i did you ever get annoyed when the no
dj versions of your tapes would come out
well yeah because i felt like that
happened because of me like i
literally feel like people got but it
was it was
it was pardon annoying and it was part
complimentary you know because one of
the reasons why
i think it started to happen is because
a lot of music off the tapes
you know would would have to live in
other places right right with the radio
js and radio and so forth so
you know they literally had to to create
that you know what i'm saying and i
you know i tried to once that became a
thing i was like
how can i navigate around this so i was
like all right let me kind of
you know uh um you know come back fall
back a little bit as far as
how boisterous i am on the tapes to try
to make people still not do it
no dj version it didn't always work they
still didn't know dj versions but
you know um i'm one that kind of you
know i don't
i don't i try not to get caught in like
i don't i don't want to call it
bitterness like yo if that's the way it
is all right let me figure out how to
work around what i'm saying so like you
know i'll do a currency tape and
verde terrace i can't scream on a
currency's music the way i do
[ __ ] you know whoever little brother
yeah exactly i get it so yeah i mean you
know i took it as a
as a form of compliment too like i think
we later grew in to like
let them have it there's so many people
oh [ __ ] let's be like yo can we get the
cheesy music with no talking on it
we go like no [ __ ] yeah you know yeah
well you know you'd be
[ __ ] whatever strip club across
america i've been in yeah and they're
playing the drama [ __ ] version
right in the club and it's it's mr
thanksgiving
i think it was a little off but i think
a little bit most
50 of it i noticed when i meet people
for the first time they say yo and these
these people
had great albums great stuff right right
right and be like yo
i ain't gonna lie we just thought y'all
was gonna turn us down on the tape so we
just did it without y'all
you know what i mean i don't know if i
ever told you i just just random people
i ran into
like bro i just didn't think about
asking i just thought it was a shot in
the dark
that was gone you wasn't gonna listen
cause there's so many people that used
to hit us on myspace like of course of
course you know
i still hear it to this day about some
of these producers they're like bro i
used to hit you on my space
hey you're your spot yeah boy one needs
to send me packs
every day you know it's just so many
people and i think that's what happened
a lot of that time was like damn no dj
version it's like a lot of people just
ain't
ain't saying ass but you know still to
this day people will tell you that
it's just not the same you know it's not
the same it's not a process
it's not the same for sure yeah um canon
what do you i mean on the production
side
um what do you work like do you have any
[ __ ] come like coming soon or
like i know you're working with
everybody so yeah i mean it's it's crazy
as 2020 was man i i was 25 placements in
just quietly
he quietly had a crazy year i really had
you know about 30 but there's something
right he's didn't go across you know
right right right
it's just that's quiet because they say
the new producer gets three placements a
year
and i'm 41 still getting 25 to
30. it's crazy so i'm happy for that you
know this year is probably going to be
even better because last year i set my
goal to make 500 beats in one year
and i normally don't work that hard and
i did it so i have
tons of leftovers of you watching this
you're going to tap in for some pizza
i'll send you a pack
i mean you just said you you uh you
seeing killer mike
working with him on the low really and i
think you're very good
yeah yeah yeah so i've been working with
him we've been
we talked on the phone two hours about
everything and then the last 30 minutes
to be like yo
music i got bars i'm gonna show you the
pad because a lot of times we've been
me and killer mike been trying to work
since 2008 fire and it just never worked
but it wasn't like
this is your first time getting in
absolutely oh [ __ ] but he's always
yo it's crazy when you sit down for five
minutes send me some beats and i would
send them beats
even through run the jewels it was like
he would take he's like yo
i'm gonna do to run the jewels when i
get off my own i do it so
this is one of them like pet peeve
projects that i'm like okay
finally about to do something but the
record that he just sent me he didn't
tell me he was saying he just sent it to
him he didn't say a word
i was like oh okay nice yeah that's
probably the one i heard yeah
what's fire about cannon two on a
production is like the same way we
navigate
just kind of like errors and genres he
does
um on the production side too like he's
in with you know
generational artists as well as new
[ __ ] and you know
like young [ __ ] coming out shows like
cannon can
can play in a lot of you know what i
mean yeah it's true
a lot a lot of rubbish just dropped a
mixtape i'm on that
um it's just so much you know but
production is her [ __ ] yeah herbo
i'm just trying to
really my my next wave is seti hendrix
really because i wanna i know what he
you're like honed in with him
yeah there i i had to i had to just chop
myself off i was
people were saying i was using a bad
word with him but i i called him the
trap r kelly
and because he has like trap antics not
because he's pissing on women
he has bro his melodies no they're crazy
[ __ ] and he could do
so much and it's like bro it reminded me
what
some like woman's threat like r kelly
joints and like
some of them joints and i was like yo he
need like pain but on that level pain
like he talking that [ __ ] but
it's like woman's threat you know what
i'm saying right real [ __ ]
and i think that once i let him get off
what he got to get off now just to be in
the street i'm just going to jump into
like okay
i tried it once we had hands down which
was a dope ass record
um and it did well for people but i want
to just kind of
bring him in to where he could see like
oh [ __ ]
now i'm cooking with gas right so well
you gotta focus on that
you mentioned teddy run down before we
wrap up like you guys
have a full roster so kind of you know
what's what's next who's next and
you know give everybody kind of the
rundown on what's next for the label
i mean jack off to a
wonderful start you know i mean uzi's
off to a great start
pretty sure he's ready to drop this year
seti is
he's moving through a situation where we
got a new video two new videos it's
about to drop that's gonna be crazy
but still working on those projects and
we also got a
uh illuminati which is a fan favorite on
tick tock and all them just been the fan
favorite though this is snapper yeah
new success she's been in this space for
about four years
uh carvina jones is uh r b artist we
we tapped into that i think that
secretly
we've always did a different a lot of
music like i started off my first
mixtape drawing was selling was a r b
mixtape
um lake's always been in an r b world he
knows that like the back of his hands
right
he's always been in it was relaxation uh
tapes and just different things
and i think that we're gonna bust open a
whole nother space
when we get her going she's a special
great talent right
um and those are things i was [ __ ]
focusing with now but i think
mostly the uh seti
is kind of the next step yeah i just
feel it you know how you feel something
yeah
i feel every i feel the energy too feel
it i feel it it's just going
one connection and then everybody gonna
be like yo
you know what i'm saying take that one
record that's it that's it that's it
yeah so uh all right well look i
appreciate y'all sitting down with me
absolutely appreciate you coming out man
i love the
studio and you guys are killing it man
so fun fact
the room we're in now um what's poppin
was made in here
okay it was probably the first record
that was made in this building in the
new generation now building
which we built this building um
because of the success of little uzian
generation now from
starting at mean streets wow well first
record
that's how it goes special room in here
shout outs all those guys man
shout out to the whole roster shout out
to uzi and i just want to shout out jack
hargo for
keeping caucasian humor alive
does he be saying [ __ ] it's like none
other dude
no but it's like it's me white boy humor
that white boy i always tell them i'm
like bro these these [ __ ] don't
get whiteboard humor just it's different
i might need i may need like an hour
board to hear
your white boy humor yeah it's suspect
it's suspect as [ __ ] it's not like okay
yours is yeah for sure oh okay yeah
yeah oh guys can get away with murder oh
yeah yeah i don't even want to talk
about [ __ ]
you know what i mean put that in our
group chat enemy dude
these guys curve the [ __ ] out of them
yeah these guys hate my guts anyway
um you guys uh i'm looking forward to
your year on the producer side thank you
bro
drama um i know was it last year you put
out the record west side gun
um was it the year before was it last
year it was last year it was last year
we got something brewing
more drama new drama yeah i got some i
got some some [ __ ] coming
all right well listen be on the lookout
and you know like
you're uh i don't have anything coming
yes he does money
money got all the money he has a lot of
money more money
money and he's also the founder of the
paul george fan club i am a laker fan
he loves pg-13 pg can ball yes he can
you can't peter you don't pg don't hate
me but you know man
we have arguments about this pg you can
ball bro
all right there it is perfect man